[ YouTube Learning ]
Now you know how to ask students a single question,
or how to give them long form assignments
using Google Classroom.
It’s also easy to create Quiz Assignments
which have many questions in them!
And the best part is that you don’t have to grade them.
Google Classroom does it for you!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
Pick the class in which
you want to add the Quiz Assignment.
Go to ClassWork, click on create,
and then select Quiz Assignment.
Did you notice something?
Google Classroom automatically created a Google
form for you.
Wait, what’s that?
Google Forms is a tool that helps you measure student
progress, administer tests and much more!
You will see how easy this tool is for creating quizzes!
Okay back to our original screen.
Give your quiz assignment a title,
and an appropriate description.
If it’s a graded quiz,
it will be a good idea
to keep the Grade Importing option on…
Here, the word ‘grade’ means
the Test Scores of your students….
and then you can
open the Google Form by clicking here.
This is the Screen you will see now!
You can name your quiz by editing this section!
You can then tell your students what this quiz is
all about using the description box here.
To make it a little more lively,
you can click here
to add a theme or an image to your quiz...
The first question box is
generated by Google Forms by default.
To add your second question, you simply have to
click on the PLUS icon you see here!
Now you are ready to post your
first question of this Quiz!
The beauty about Google Forms is that it gives
you a choice to ask many different types of questions!
It could be a short answer question,
or a long answer question or
even a Multiple Choice question maybe!
Let’s pick Multiple Choice for now!
Let me add a sample question with 4 answer choices
Once you have entered your question,
you should also add an Answer Key.
You should mention the correct answer here,
and assign points to this question.
So if the student answers this correctly,
she will get 2 points.
The ‘Answer Feedback’ button is important as well.
Clicking on it allows you to enter the feedback required
for students depending on their answer.
If they answer incorrectly,
we could write something like this,
and give a video link for reference.
And for correct answers,
we could give feedback like this.
And then you click on Save.
If you want to make it mandatory for the student
to attempt a question, change this to ‘Required’.
This will not allow the student to go ahead and
submit the quiz unless she has answered this one.
You could also add images to your question
or answer options by clicking here!
Now let me add another question here
by clicking on the PLUS icon.
Well, what if you want to see the handwritten
detailed answers that your students have written?
Here’s the question.
In that case, we can select the “File Upload” option here
and click on Continue.
These are the different file types
your students can upload.
So your students can write detailed answers
maybe in their notebook and click pictures
and upload images.
Or if the answer runs into pages,
they can also upload a pdf file.
If some student is finding it difficult to write
because of an injury, she can also upload
an audio file by narrating the answer.
As you can see, there are plenty of options here.
Interesting isn’t it?
You could add as many questions as you like,
and your quiz will keep getting auto-saved.
If you wish to see how students are going
to see your quiz, you can use the preview
option right here!
What if you want your students to attempt
your quiz a maximum of just one time?
Well, you have that option too.
You just need to go to the Settings section
and click on Limit to one response.
In the middle, we see the presentation section here.
You can also choose to show your students
a progress bar which tells them how many questions
they have answered and how many are left.
Your quiz is now ready.
You may close this tab, and come back to this page.
You could also refresh the page once
for your changes to take effect.
You will see your quiz assignment here
on your dashboard now!
Clicking on edit will open the quiz assignment again.
Here you can make it a part of a topic.
And then you can assign or schedule for a later date!
Your students now will be able to see your quiz
in that particular topic of your class!
And once your students have attempted the quiz,
you will see all the responses in the
Grades section here.
Let’s click on the Quiz Assignment here.
We can see that all 9 students of your class
have turned the assignment in,
which means they have submitted it.
To get the scores,
we just have to click on ‘Import Grades’ here.
And then we can see the scores of the students
on the left.
Clearly, Google Classroom did the job
of automatically grading them.
It does save you a lot of time as
no manual checks are required.
You'd have to manually check only the
detailed or subjective answers written by your students!
Google Forms is one of the easiest tools to use
for quizzes and assessments ,
and believe me here.
If you spend just 2 focussed hours on it,
you will understand almost 80% of it.
So don’t let anything hold you back!
Happy teaching!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]